[Music]
with its what if series disney recently
embarked on an interesting journey in
its serious scene the concept is quite
simple but all the more fascinating as a
result the marvel universe is approached
from completely new perspectives over
the course of the series and the mcu is
virtually recreated from scratch in
concrete terms this means that various
key scenes from the mcu which are
familiar from movies and comics are
given alternative scenarios everything
is based on the comic book series of the
same name at the end of the series
season 1 there was a battle of various
superheroes from the craziest parallel
universes against an overpowered and old
familiar mcu villain a truly exciting
series finale the outcome of which we do
not want to reveal here of course either
way there is plenty of potential for a
second season the only question is
whether those responsible see the same
way in fact director brian andrews and
screenwriter ac bradley recently
confirmed to entertainment weekly that
the script for season 2 is already in
the works they want to stay true to the
anthology format and incorporate new
heroes especially those from phase 4 of
the mcu temporarily there was some talk
that the events from what if might also
be relevant for the upcoming films of
the mcu which arthur bradley more or
less denied nevertheless some fans
speculate that some characters from the
series will appear in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness others are
sure that we will already meet familiar
what-if characters in the upcoming
spider-man no way home whether the
rumors are true is something we cannot
find out until the release of the two
movies at the earliest currently it is
unclear when the second season of what
if will be released but late 2022 seems
quite viable
the upcoming star wars series of the
book of boba fett was announced this
past week the accompanying poster which
was published on the star wars social
media channels is already depicting the
infamous bounty hunter and full costume
along with the release date of december
29th 2021 tim wearer morrison will be
seen in the eponymous role while ming-na
when will take on the role of the elite
mercenary fanuc shand the storyline
picks up right where the second season
of the main series the mandalorian left
off and will presumably start with boba
fett and fanuc chant returning to
tatooine the team working behind the
camera is also well staffed as disney is
relying on familiar crew members from
the mandalorian including producers dave
filoni and john favreau for example the
two of them are also said to have
directed individual episodes themselves
as the director robert rodriguez we are
eager to see the outcome of the book of
boba fett and look forward to the
premiere set for december 29th 2021
hardly any other series is currently
influencing pop culture as much as squid
game beat by memes tweets or
unintentional spoilers at first glance
the series plot is quite straightforward
456 in-depth people fight for a gigantic
prize money in a total of 6 children's
games the downside is that despite of
their colorful design the games are not
children friendly at all and the
slightest of mistakes can cost them
their lives a risk that many are willing
to take the success story comes from
south korean director and screenwriter
rang donghyuk who spent almost 10 years
working on the realization of his
project only to keep facing rejections
now the finished result surprised
millions of fans around the globe
logically the question now arises
whether and when there will be a second
season crater huang cannot imagine a
production process similar to that of
the first season as he was physically
and mentally at his breaking point while
working on squid game which is why he
doesn't even want to think about new
episodes right now netflix on the other
hand has naturally profited from the
surprise hit and appears to want to
continue its contender for the most
successful netflix series of all time
without the series creator that would
hardly be possible however he doesn't
want to have anything further to do with
the series for the time being and would
rather devote himself to other projects
in an interview with vulture netflix
global head of tv bella bayaria talks
about finding the right structure for
one in addition to his other projects
thus netflix is going to attempt
everything to produce a second season as
quickly as possible with huang's
participation especially given the very
short-lived duration of hypes this might
possibly be a good idea but first one
would need to get other experienced
writers and directors aboard in fact
that's his main requirement for
continuing to work on squid game with
that said we are sure that netflix ceo
ted serranos is already personally on
his way to find highly qualified staff
for the new season as soon as there's
more news about squid game season 2 we
will of course let you know
in 2012 sony's animated film hotel
transylvania was a huge success the
story of count dracula yeti frankenstein
quasimodo jonathan and the like not only
enchanted children around the world but
also made the franchise immensely
popular fans are all the more eager to
see the fourth and final part which is
supposed to be the culmination of the
series johnny courts the acceptance of
his father-in-law love and transforms
himself into a monster without further
ado the transformation of johnny has
worked but he has also turned his
monster friends into ordinary people at
the same time causing a lot of commotion
in hotel transylvania besides the clock
is ticking since the protagonists have
to quickly make sure that they return to
their original form otherwise they might
have to remain in their new bodies
forever the release of hotel
transylvania transfomania is now
actually within reach because as
deadline reports amazon has purchased
the animated spectacle hence it will be
available on amazon prime videos
starting on january 14th 2022 a
theatrical release had eventually been
ruled out by sony pictures following
multiple postponements
transformers rise of the beast is one of
the most anticipated action hits of the
coming year after the spin of bumblebee
from 2018 it's now time for a new film
in the main series the new director
stephen keppel jr should breathe new
life into this somewhat rusty franchise
a first preview is available on the
instagram channel of the 33 year old
where two pictures have been posted one
of them shows the director himself
surrounded by some well-known
transformers you can see the world
famous optimus prime truck the black and
yellow camaro from bumblebee the iconic
porsche 911 as well as a vw bus and a
motorcycle the second image on the other
hand features three decepticons who are
no doubt warming up in preparation for
combat with the autobots the story takes
place in 1994 and thus a few years after
the events of bumblebee at the center is
the ever popular optimus prime who
together with his autobots must defend
humanity against all sorts of enemies in
addition to the decepticons the factions
of the praticons terracons and maximals
known from beast wars make their
appearance we are definitely looking
forward to transformers rise of the
beasts with a theatrical release date of
june 24th 2022
the last screen movie was released
almost 10 years ago after creator and
director wes craven passed away in 2015
it didn't seem like there would be any
new content for the franchise however a
fifth part was only a matter of time in
the end and so the filming of scream 5
took place at the end of last year an
insider now seems to have new
information about the horror slasher the
twitter user of euroannon who has
already established a reputation for
accurate leaks in the past published
some plot details however he did keep
them spoiler free thus dewey and gayle
are said to have divorced in the
meantime partly because they disagreed
about life in the big city meanwhile
gail has got her own tv show while dewey
has returned to woodsboro though is no
longer a sheriff sydney is a proud
mother and is reportedly married to a
very special person whose name will no
doubt sound familiar to scream fans and
cause a lot of discussion is this a hint
at an appearance of patrick dempsey as
mark and kate we'll see there's also
news about the first trailer which is
supposed to be shown in theaters on
october 10th and will have a length of 2
minutes and 21 seconds to top it off we
now know that the fifth film won't be
called scream 5 but will simply be
titled scream which according to the
insider is a dig at other horror movie
remakes that use the exact same name as
the original scream is set to in
theaters on january 14 2022
the expandables franchise is synonymous
with big action and even bigger names
although it often lacks a deep storyline
nevertheless there are many fans who are
looking forward to the recently
confirmed fourth part of this series
filming is set up begun on september
29th in london as green daily reported
returning to the big screen rsl master
stallone is barney ross jason statham
asleep christmas dolph lundgren as gary
jansen and randy coacher as tall road
apart from them the newcomer curtis
jackson aka 50 cent megan fox andy
garcia as well as tony yaw have been
announced just in time for the sort of
shooting three more rather unknown
actors have joined the cast namely jacob
scipio sheila shah and levi tran
director scott walk who already directed
the need for speed movie will be in
charge of the film we're curious to see
where the filming runs smoothly and are
looking forward to the expandables 4.
unfortunately a release date is not
known yet
if you also want to be brought up to
date regarding the upcoming game of
thrones spin-off house of the dragon you
can check out the first teaser trailer
that was published on our channel this
week it is an absolute must-see not only
for game of thrones fans see you next
time
[Music]